I'm going to start a presentation my
name is Anton Anton off I'm replacing
Mitch stone Hawker he was supposed to
give the presentation here I'll explain
a little bit more about Christy shelf
this is Mitch's company Christy's his
wife she's chronically ill which is a
former trader
a financial kind of guy has different
financial companies he started doing
health care related stuff because of his
wife and in some sense he has a
full-time job of taking care of the
current conditions of his wife I'm going
to have three screens here this is the
presentation this one here some we're
going to see different different
websites whatever Christy Alpha is what
is the company image guess and this is
his wife with the chronic condition as I
mentioned the other panel here this is
the this intellij I can I'll use it
probably to explain some of the things
I'm doing for certain things but back to
the presentation all right so the the
present the presentation voice grandma
compute communicate I did have somewhat
different somewhat different
representation of the social contract
which is in this abstract written by
Mitch it is I'm going to cover most of
the topics he wants to talk about the I
don't have for much healthcare data I'm
going to use a substitute of the
healthcare data I'm going to explain
that so first I assume people at least
to a point are interested in
conversational agents you know this is
what we are trying to do we're trying to
do conversational agents for healthcare
they certain marketing efficiency right
now not certain in
huge in American healthcare this
marketing efficiency is basically almost
everything but one of the things is what
hospitals they don't share data we don't
share algorithms everything is
proprietary
we're very slow very often when people
have certain conditions Bank in a
critical situation in some sense it's
already a little bit too late maybe not
too late but if this was you know caught
earlier they bought the quad adequate
health care would have been given to
those individuals individuals so the the
big idea of Christi shelf is to be able
to collect this data beforehand using
mobile devices using some other stuff
now here we are trying to make a
conversational agent that facilitates
this kind of form this kind of
collection of data and management of
chronic conditions I'm going to show
such a conversational agent design for
management or for diabetes so so this
here it's a simple breakdown of giving
like some kind of a map of what's going
on when we what we are trying to do
right now I personally design in this
corner I use finite state machine
machines and I use deterministic grammar
rules most of the time the deterministic
grammar rules can be extended with
stochastic rules and those two caustic
rules they don't I mean you can you can
you can continue about a deal further
and trying to stochastically derive
grammar rules that's not a trivial thing
though the other axis here it's the the
states in which we have for the
difference I do prefer the finite state
machine perspective or form of designer
conversational agent so the fine state
machines were basically like vending
machines you press g3 you put five
dollars or puts whatever sound amount of
money if you have an
money you get chocolate if you don't you
know it doesn't it doesn't give it gives
you just the money you put back so you
go for different you can have different
combinations entering the money first
putting the code and so forth so finite
state machines this is one way to design
conversational agents this is what I do
most of the time in some sense you
there's no way to escape this either
people use it explicitly or implicitly
when people try to design conversational
agents in with stochastic methods
they're basically expecting with the
lots of dialogues with lots of text the
system to to derive the to derive those
states okay I'm not going to I shouldn't
be dwelling too much on this but if you
so in this blog post I have described I
think pretty well the principles behind
creating and programming codomain
specific languages one of the things I
use a lot it's called morphological
analysis and this is something we are
going to see in the conversational
agents I'm going to represent to show
you here this is on github I have a I
have a repository code conversational
agents in this conversational agents
there is a project bukoza and let's go
to diagrams so in this glucose diagrams
okay so this is such a this is this is
the application of the so called
morphological analysis in glucose ax I'm
not going to go for this but basically
we are trying to find two orthogonal
axes which describe the situation we are
trying to to generate a grammar to make
the conversational agent here you see
the breakdown between the data types we
are going to use for designing a
diabetes conversational agent like like
nutritional logs like different
databases for physical activities and so
forth and then we on the vertical axis
here we have different type of
functionalities obviously we can you
know I mean this can be extensive list
you can
you can do a similar table which which I
think it's probably here which gives
them gives the breakdown of the
different of the different algorithms
that can be used alright so with the
domain-specific languages I can actually
show you like I mean just to be a little
bit more concrete this should be life I
hope all right so what is happening here
I have this simple language which is you
know you say I like milk I love milk I
want ice cream whatever right and it is
this language just gives you just gives
you back certain well I'm using Wolfram
Alpha and the internet connection is
very slow but you can see here I hope
you can you can see here how it does you
know it does actually through the
Wolfram Alpha call it does give you the
calories of the demands or wherever it
is so this conversational agent is just
this it just make a statement about your
food preferences and it parses this
abstract syntax trees you see here and
so basically you can see how love food
has been connected to love food calories
here and love food color is is basically
it's doing some you know computation ski
I mean we basically see how we call him
go from mouth and so forth
I mean if this this probably won't
finish in either actually I don't care
at this point about it but this is an
example output from Wolfram Alpha if you
I mean basically I'm taking in this
particular implementation just taking
this dis oughta change doing you know
using hips to to make this response
table what was earlier shown earlier
alright so so glucose um I was made for
different screen if the glucose was made
as a competition entry for for Alexa
diabetes challenge the Alexa diabetes
challenge and so
this is organized by Amazon we not my my
intro this entry was not accepted at the
at the very beginning because I didn't
discuss security for some reason
security of the data and you know was
very important for them which I mean I
understand but whatever nevertheless as
I said this is very well in my opinion
document documentation designed effort
and you can see different I mean like
say this diagram for example with
somewhere here and you can see some
other diagrams if you go to this github
repository there's some other diagrams
showing different stages about bukoza
so what is in this diagram this
particular design it has two goals it
needs to serve individuals like people
who actually have the chronical
condition but it also can serve
physicians who want to actually see
statistics in general like you know for
a cohort of patients like everyone who
has BMI above 90 29 and you know they're
older than 35 and they live in Alabama
or whatever so that's why this color
coding is doing that so the the green
ones were more like on the physician
sites we're basically using statistics
on the whole set of patients who utilize
this service the the ones the ones here
on the top where the core the core
Chronicle condition management's modules
the yellow ones they are more like like
motivational like you know you want to
banter with some other debris people how
much you lost you know how many people
if you feel competitive there's some
kind of social networking element so
with several elements in this what is
happening here I mean it's it's here you
see this is in the background but it's
basically these are the different
grammars the difference finite state
machines and etc which are being
designed to behind the behind the scene
alright so actually I I would like
to show you a possible grammar here
which was in the I wasn't able to
download this from from Google but for
example look at this PDF and you can see
the difference on boarding grammars and
etc and so there are different rules
like these these grammars will allow you
to say my name is dis and I'm you know
I'm 29 years old and I'm the beak and so
forth and actually I think I have a
better bet on Pierre here about this
like this design document there's an
example here like so this is the
important module in which we proclaim
different parameters of the user then we
do certain you know then we actually
we're supposed to be able to query to be
able to handle this kind of queries and
you know to to provide certain certain
explanations and so forth ok well here
you can see some kind of statistics this
is from the physician perspective to
kind of see statistics of our population
of people I am not sure how important is
this I think more important discuss this
next diagram which again you know
apparently I should zoom out from it so
thank you this is an important this here
this diagram shows an important
methodology which I only kind of
illustrate adhere in this particular
example with the food so you see this is
this this here it's a Baku snore code
this is a human readable code from this
backhoe snore code I generate parsers if
we look at the output here these are
this this apart DISA parsed like for
example this one was turned into this
parcel this is actually code generated
from this from this particular you know
formalism for explaining grammars after
this is done so back to this picture
here
so we we we do get a Garrard
specifications and etc we do some
parsing experiments after we have
figured out what kind of grammars we
want to implement then we generate the
grammars this is a very powerful
technique
I have implemented this this generation
of sorry we generate the parcels from
the grammars I have implemented several
languages Mathematica is the best for
this way some possibility to modify the
parsers and do some other stuff here
what we supplemented is this activity is
for example we can enhance it with
different studies like entity name
recognition and etc using some different
modules like spell check and engineering
recognition you can improve your parsing
abilities so in let me show so because
this is one of the things we are trying
to do and if you've been in my previous
talk it's somewhat related to this I'm
using here wine data as a representative
of vitals of Vital Signs time series and
these distributions you see here
although they're for wine type of you
know chemicals or whatever we're very
similar to the distributions you'll see
about say heart rate and you know like
respiratory rate and so forth so so this
classification classification pipeline
we actually have a way this is a
domain-specific language programming the
main specific language and we have a way
with grammars and parcels to map into
this in this particular pipelines my
previous talk if you haven't seen it my
previous talk in this conference was
describing well what is important here
from Christie's health perspective and
what we are kind of you know pushing is
what we actually do have this this
decision fresh shots like this is very
important you need to dis receive
operating characteristics they come from
the Second World War when you have a
Raider and trying to figure out an
airplane is this airplane yours or enemy
airplane so how much you want to have
any enemy airplane at the back of your
arm
how much you want to shoot your own
plane so similarly here how much you
want to leave someone leave someone
who's with critical condition to die
how much don't so if you have like two
two teams or three teams of physicians
and nurses obviously it's a you know you
can spread them out in bacon monitor
different people if you have one team
and you know the hospital work is
basically two different buildings how do
you schedule where they go you need to
make be able to make a selection this is
happening in this way one of the things
I really like about soul it's about this
we use quantile regression granted
quantile regression I mean it's just the
better way of doing of doing time series
analysis so in this particular case what
I want to show is what I'm actually
using some generating some random point
points here you can see if I generate so
I have a contour regression solution
this here this quantile regression you
see the pipeline here imagine what I
have randomly randomly put this kind of
I can randomly select this kind of
elements this is what is happening here
this what I'm showing you if I generate
this again we will see different you
know different pipelines also let me let
me run this this is basically so I'm
making a bunch of random tests and then
I am running them this is one way for me
to catch the mistakes it's extremely
important with this pipelining like what
we saw the pipelines here for this is
not quantile regression this is the
classification but it's exactly the same
principle it's extremely important when
you map natural language into this kind
of pipelines to be able to fail
gracefully or you know you need to
design for failure so that's why I am
I'm testing this in this way and the
finite state machines well this is this
is basically a general diagram we're not
we're using Mathematica but ultimately
we want to get out of North America I
mean we if we
go in production both Mitch and I we we
pretty good with Mathematica love it but
ultimately at some point we need to
consider getting out of Mathematica and
using some of the production production
level libraries so it's very important
for me to be able to use the libraries I
kept listed there spark and h2o h2o is
written in Java Sparky's Sparky's
certain in Scala but it's a job virtual
machine type of thing and you can see I
mean we're basically addressing this
we have grammars and conversational
agents but let you load the data
transform the data make the classifiers
test different metrics and display them
we're reading keen on miracle Dekker
medical records that the patient's in
demographic data is just conditionally
separated here we also hear from a
design which lets us capture encapsulate
the transformations in a particular way
this is the finite state machine I I was
talking about so we're waiting for a
command if the command slowed the data
we get the data again if the command
slow data we go into the state data
loaded and so forth so I'm using this
kind of this kind of state machines to
finally state machines to design the
dialogues in the conversational agents
what you saw maybe none of the talks
with Wolfram Alpha when they saying okay
differentiate that they meant the last
date it's something like this in some
sense this is more comprehensive because
I actually always know what was the last
comment and I actually can figure out I
can retrace my steps at any at any point
all right so this was it and thank you
for your attention please
[Applause]
yes yeah the way ah
it's math America yeah Mathematica but
it doesn't matter it's more conceptual
device right I mean I I use Mathematica
if you look at this I mean I need to
probably I guess accentuate just more
but if you could say where was
conversational agents but alright I do
have in my github repository for example
here they'sa this is connected to github
right if we do this this conversational
agent I mean it's fairly well-described
there's also a youtube movie doing stuff
with it I mean showing different how
different functional it's implemented if
you want to figure out how you know how
to use this fine state machines
mathematical it's it's one way to do it
right my grammars they do in some sense
the grammars themselves they have fine
state machine behind them but this is a
this is a more on a more macro level so
as I said like for example for this
phonebook phonebook type of diagrams you
can see like for example if you get a
query I want to talk to to an engineer
from what company
what is the name and so you go for this
kind of state-based this waiting for
filter you filter you filter your
queries you get only one one personal
then you can doubt you know we can make
a dial to the phone or you can just
press with a button on the list which is
being written but this this kind of just
so fine it's these are the finite States
I'm going through I can use voice to
command this I can use also in or some
other ways to interact it's I'm going to
open up on a diagram which I think is
going to explain this well and so let's
see patient conditions prediction
framework somewhere here in just a
moment
in to browse through this yeah vism okay
unfortunately this is not very good but
this is a okay I'm going to open it this
is a continuous testing cycle so I
basically this is like imagine you want
to do devops if you you know the term I
assume you want to do DevOps for data
science and
data you want to do devops for machine
learning algorithms for healthcare or
whatever right if I have changes in my
data I want to be able to run this new
data with the old classifiers I have and
see what are the results I also want to
retrain and you classify with this data
and see what results I'm going to get
and so forth you know this cycle here
I'm going to be storing both the data
and the models in the classifiers I'm
doing like if you use Java you can
always download the so-called plain Java
object so you can have a database of the
models you are producing every day with
different data and so forth and you can
actually see when somebody say it color
if you have a database use Mathematica
wah with the new you speak ok yes sir ok
yeah we can use Mathematica analyze what
happened but you know this person who
made broke the whole thing thank you